I always like seeing Empire Builders you
know what they created how they thought
of things the Hall of Mirrors are
beautiful it makes me always want to do
something bigger
[Music]
good morning good morning how do you
sleep Evan 85 wow I think I think we're
not allowed to sleep well together you
get good sleep and I get busted I get
you sleep then you get bad sleep gotta
go to bed earlier yeah so today's her
side we're a little bit rushed we have
15 minutes okay eat and go to the Palace
of Versailles yeah let's go
we just finished our breakfast we're
gonna hop on the car Uber to Versailles
you ready for a good day every day with
Nina's a good day
[Music]
we have a ride to this beautiful palace
with this handsome man let's go I'm not
beautiful oh you beautiful but that's
more subscribed to a lady okay
[Music]
what's next step
I don't know
it's the most famous inside part here
okay so we gotta kick in to see the
famous things
she can explain to me what history is
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
do you like the
the what do you call this Castle
how's my word about you yeah I get I get
a little anxious because two too many
people inside just getting
claustrophobic it was pretty it was
pretty packed it was pretty packed yeah
yeah it was nice though I mean yeah at
the end I just ran through it I just
like walked through everything I always
like seeing Empire Builders you know
what they created avocado things the hot
you know the Hall of Mirrors are
beautiful uh makes me always want to do
something bigger but I was more worried
about you the most for the most
especially the second one okay let's go
through let's get you out of here let's
get some fresh air let's get some water
and now we're going to explore the
gardens or go home I don't know let's
see how Nina's feeling
[Music]
we finished the palace in in the garden
but I feel a little hungry so we're
gonna stop at this little cafe cradle of
place creepery okay whatever okay we're
gonna have some snacks and coffee yeah a
few gifts whatever I don't know let's
just go you're okay we love you okay
let's let's get her some coffee
foreign
Nutella and bananas
you got the healthy Savory one chicken
and guacamole chicken and guacamole and
eggs let's see how famous well how good
the famous tastes
I think I'm trying to
all right
this is actually the greater gluten free
crepe with chicken cheese guacamole and
green salad
and how do you like it
anyway
let's go
that was a good little break
yeah how you feeling that was more for
you yeah I feel a little I feel a bit
better good I feel very full still I
don't know why it's only like little bit
but then it's full no that was filling
the cheese in there was really filling
yeah and she's avocado yeah and meat
that's filling that's a meal it was big
yeah yeah okay thank you it's a good
choice
now we're gonna just explore uh one of
the the only Street in Versailles for
shops and stuff okay and then we're done
okay let's go
[Music]
foreign
destination is on your right
turn right in 500 meters
it's 500 meters
we walk on this street it's not much
happening most doors are closed so we
decided you know what we're just gonna
go back to the hotel ordering an Uber
yeah and then we're gonna chill and see
four minutes away well we're feeling it
afterwards
foreign
[Music]
Seafood yeah so they're known for their
mussels and Fries here so we're gonna go
get she said she wanted fish and chips
like well fish and chips is pretty
British but the French do mussels and
Fries so we're gonna go I found a pretty
highly rated close seafood place and
fingers crossed Nina likes it
[Music]
this is it
I hope you're hungry Evan
yeah and menu looks crazy look pretty
crazy yeah look at this you know what
you want
well you get to the side
Giant
this is a gigantic plate it's huge
I'm excited thank you for ordering this
well you ordered it I just got it all
right thank you bring me here
let's go and it also comes with this pot
of soup Evan needs it all right we
finished the food very quickly
we always eat quickly well actually this
one's pretty quick we didn't finish our
food first it was the food was just okay
not as fresh as I we're twins look at us
okay yeah yeah there's some like this
anyways it's it's it's not as fresh but
whatever it's okay but thank you for
finding the food for me and then we're
gonna go home have a great night
together tomorrow is the biggest day of
all it's our anniversary our 10 year
anniversary I've got lots of special
things surprises plant
plan and if you want to see what we do
go click there it's amazing continue to
believe and we'll see you there